viva las vegas who is sponsoring this
next segment is back this weekend and
earlier i spoke with creator tom ingram
to get all the details on this
rockabilly weekend
hey tom it's great to see you again
buddy let's start off why don't you tell
everyone more about viva las vegas
okay well vive las vegas it's a four day
a night rockabilly festival and a car
show that takes place at the orleans
hotel in vegas
and this year from the 14th to the 17th
of april
what okay when what when was year number
one
year number one was 1998
april 1998
25 years this is a big celebration this
year what what has changed from 1998 to
the show this year
well
um the biggest change is when we moved
from the gold coast to the orleans hotel
because we needed a larger space
um and it's just grown in size and we've
added things
as we've gone along we've added more
sort of parts to the event yeah the car
show grew enormously
we've added more burlesque and then
meetup groups and more general venues
happening at the same time let's go down
from the the happenings
that are taking place over the weekend
we've got a pool party right
actually three days of pool parties
you guys do it right you guys doing
right
we have the classic car show which if
you love cars you're gonna love the car
show can people still enter their
vehicles into the car show yes they can
they can do that on the website whenever
they want right up until the day before
perfect we've got uh live music and in
the bands you want to talk about that'll
be out there yeah we're going to have
the go-getters from sweden there's big
sandy in the flywhite boys from
california there's the rhythm shakers
we got the
um surfer jets an all girl surfband
coming to play as well
tell me more about the burlesque events
i see it here on the the press release
the more about the burlesque events
well we've got the burlesque showcase
which we're doing three performances of
that and that's being hosted by john
waters this year
um there's the burlesque competition
which takes place on the saturday night
and then there's six separate
shows of burlesque bingo
it's it's non-stop action uh which is
what i love about the event indoors
outdoors by the pool every everyone is
welcome to to this weekend
is this new but it says here weddings
are you guys doing weddings this year
we've done weddings for quite a few
years we have a temporary wedding chapel
out at the car show and people go they
can either get legally married or they
can do commitment ceremonies or any of
their vows
and that that's busy all day
i love it viva las vegas it's such a
great feel-good event how do people get
tickets and how do they get more
information um just go to the website
which is viva las vegas dot net that's
got all of the information it's where
you can get the tickets and everything
viva las vegas rockabilly weekend at the
orleans thursday through sunday well
actually back to live on thursday so
it's april 14th through the 17th for
tickets visit viva lasvegas.net